now what about when you're doing your
sets in a comedy club have you do you
have people that get into it with you
that say okay you've crossed the line I
don't like this or do they mostly um at
this point people are coming because
they like what I do but like before I
got to a certain point yeah I had a lot
I had a lot of those I remember some
woman I said something about animals and
I remember she got so mad at me and she
came up you know I was selling my DVDs
so long ago this was and uh I don't know
she got into it with me
about this stupid joke and I remember
she was so proud of herself in the end
she goes you know just she goes just to
let you know she goes I'm a
card-carrying member of PETA like she
got a degree or something and I was just
like what is that like 25 bucks you just
sort of picked your way into that
and how'd that go over
for me it was fun it was like that was
one of my favorite things is when people
would get mad and then they would like
yell at you they would do all kinds of
weird [ __ ] am I very pissed off this one
guy I think I was in Texas and I said
something liberal that he didn't like
and he came up afterwards and he shook
my hand and I shook his hand and he just
goes I just paid
he showed you
no and I just laughed I didn't give a
[ __ ] I also was a really angry guy and
uh the [ __ ] I used to say it was just a
lot of it was [ __ ] you know I don't
know what it was and I remember a lot of
times people dragging people out like
people didn't give a [ __ ] were dragging
somebody out who was yelling at me my
favorite thing was the person this guy
wanted to beat the [ __ ] out of me during
the show and they threw him out in
classic Comedy Club security the guy
gets back in to beat the [ __ ] out of me
but he stood in the line at the DVDs
waiting to beat the [ __ ] out of the fact
that he's very patient and he's he's a
rule he's a rule follower yes so he had
to go bounce like that guy third guy
down that guy's gonna punch me in the
face when it's his turn can you go over
there and uh get rid of him yeah that
was you know there was a lot of that
type of stuff you know I don't know I
was I I referenced the Red Rocks special
because that's the last one I've seen
you do you have another one coming out
right do you have another special coming
out or that's going to be it for a while
yeah that'll be it that'll be it for a
while I don't really like where my ACT
is right now I'm trying to it's too much
of this not enough of this so I always
have to have like that balance of
annoying people and then sort of also
being like all right I'm an idiot you
know
yeah like yeah but I think and this is
worth talking about like I know over
covid I I ran into you came by still
going Conan
place it never existed
that's my little pet peeve it's my
little pet oh I got the mask on
um I got it really into vaccines during
covet I can't stop getting them now
do they make you got the shingles one I
got my second one do they make you do
they make you
sick the shingles one the first time I
felt a little weird and uh and then the
second one I I had a little bit of a
headache yeah the next day but like to
not have like shingles whatever
I got those ones I got those years ago
when I was first starting out in La I
got shoes and slightly were you a ginger
with shingles yeah and guess what I got
them on my optic nerve oh my eye and so
it just half my face literally half
because the nerves of your face are
symmetrical got swollen and I was in
excruciating pain and couldn't drive
anything look at you laughing because I
just pictured you in like a Batman movie
like being that that face off his name's
two-faced not face all right Two-Face
Two-Face and shingles I had been coming
for Gotham
laughs
half my face was completely mobile was
red swollen and I couldn't I couldn't I
could like this is like this is killing
you my pain uh I'm just thinking of your
poor wife you just screaming in agony no
I wasn't married I had I was I was
living alone is this in L.A
1987. they had shingle Spanish yeah I
think it started with me no it was
patient zero and uh I walked but you
[ __ ] monkey or something
that's how shingles came about
[Applause]
God damn
that's goddamn Conan O'Brien
catches cracking fingers to himself
let's just say I may or may not have
finger [ __ ] a bat okay what you doing
you're wrong
it's what people did
first of all it's a bat that's still a
mammal yeah right so that's still within
the Bible yeah that's fair game man can
let can [ __ ] with mammal uh yeah Old
Testament uh yeah he's laughing about a
man laying with another bat
the older New Testament no so yeah I
remembered walking because I had no one
to drive me and I couldn't I walked to I
my favorite thing ever I'm the height I
am now but I was so I'm six four but I
weighed about 150 pounds and half my
face was half my pumpkin head was
swollen and deformed and I was
staggering down the street to see her
side
and it hurts so much dragging a foot
going I went to Harvard
someday they'll put an athletic bottom
on a wingtip too
just chunks in my face falling off I'm
still better than all of you
oh that always goes well